ó
vejam só pessoal muitos lá embora o
pessoal de quem fala em dar que sejam
muito bem vindos é mais um menino e eu
gostava de ver aqui um vídeo que eu não
sei se vai dar certo mas não sou eu
comprei olha aí eu acho que é uma
massinha meio fly no meio baixo do lugar
eu não faço ideia é méxico é muito
parecido assim é aí
vejam só é muito louco isso é muito
parecido antonio mas ao mesmo tempo é
uma pasta muito estranho e supostamente
queria quando a massa seca que salta
muito o nosso hoje pessoal hoje vamos
tentar fazer uma bola gigante só tentou
nesta tanto pula-pula sei lá mas que vai
saltar vai espetar estava comprei muitas
embalagens estão assim há muitas mesmo
eu acho que eu tenho mais 32 então acho
que é suficiente para fazer uma bola
gigante isso seja em casa gosta um time
que tem embaixo esta ex time e assim eu
consegui saber se vocês gostam que
possivelmente possam trazer mais coisas
se bem que isso não é bem flying mas já
percebi se vocês forem novos aqui no
canal pessoal já se inscrevam e deixei
muito leque que neste vídeo agora é hora
que nós vamos construir a nossa bombinha
mas primeiro nós vamos fazer aqui nos
testes e vai ser já com esta maçã é
muito estranho lugar nenhum e não fica
tipo mdf que tipo veiculada olha aí
produção tamanho milan então é muito
mutável esta massa e quando ela seca ela
fica de banho dura mesmo isso assim que
ela saiu eu acho mas vamos tentar agora
eu vou fazer se uma bolinha assim tentar
porque ela ainda está bastante molhada
sei lá tinha um líquido estranho dentro
eu acho que é um homem qualquer ou assim
é mais ou menos uma bolinha vamos lá
tentar se lançar 13 21 vai faltar mesmo
ainda neste grupo forte unido eu vou
tentar com muita força para 321 vai
muitas vezes tentam agora nós
comprovamos que está bolinhas alta
juntar mais e maine e mais macia e só
teve uma bola gigante olha só como fica
bonito verde eo amarelo e isso já fica
muito grande não terminam quase lhes
falta muito sério isso espera uma bola e
só falta vocês acham que está bom e vai
funcionar como tem muito em baixo esta
bola só que teve horas o álbum então
abrir as nossas bolsinhas todas massinha
e vamos juntar tudo só uma bola para lá
podem ver nós temos aqui muitas cores
têm amarelo cor de rosa vermelho verde
então a bola vai ficar com muitas cores
mesmo ela consegue fazer trabalho
só parei só tenho mais aqui que vem bem
sim meios secas e tem outras que vêm com
um líquido muito estranho pra minha mão
de tipo móvil muito muito estranho ser e
nós já temos aqui duas três quatro cinco
seis certas cento mas sim mas vamos
tentar unir agora sustenta e qual é o
tamanho
embora lá fora amarelo jantar aqui já
nesta mais uma verde e uma vermelha que
o preço da internet com castanho sei lá
mais uma ver né
estou aqui duas juntas oc2 ver sempre
assim e que juntas rocha é muito
satisfatório sério é muito bom olha isso
é muito gostoso o cartola que temos mais
ou menos uma bolinha não estarão só vez
dois uma o salto alto porque o pessoal
não tem como falar agora é só adicionar
mais mas sim é um cientista nunca falha
é barato agora lado só usava em todas as
embalagens mas não só a quantidade do
pasta que o tanque olha isso é muito bom
é muita massinha olha isso tem muitos
cursos é preciso muita força pra amassar
e de pernas para o ar uma bola
gigantesca só assim já está muito grande
o clássico no triunfo sobre isso agora
vou ter que juntar esta foi muito grande
estou muito cansado de ficar uma bola
leiza agora é só continuar a ajuda ao
país sem muita força e mandou porta e
essa é nossa boa saúde tanto de som aí
violenta muito perfeita se bem que ela
não houvesse muitas leis da física
porque ela é o tempo ela começa a querer
deixar a equipe sozinhas estática tabela
vai estender a parte mais frágil porém
sua parte baixa está a ficar mais leis é
que ele está bem e chutado
agora sua única coisa que eu preciso é
que esta bola fique mais sólido e para
isso nós temos que explorar um processo
de secagem então nós vamos contar com a
ajuda do nosso química orgânica é louco
ou ligar ou desligar que o setor já está
agora é diferente não funciona
vai funcionar agora sim ele ganso só
vamos fazer isso certo e que está só a
nossa bola só que tanto o máximo que
consegui fazer o tempo máximo de dom da
lei
vamos ver se ela salta para 13 jun a ela
já são também mais mexe ela precisa de
uma queda muito maior mas a altitude
velocidade é porque isso não é o
suficiente então nós vamos investir lá
fora e ver se elas atuam na europa para
lá pessoal já estamos e que foi o
primeiro texto vai ser contra o chão só
assim leva embora 321 mesmo que fosse um
bom futebol
isso mesmo ainda tentar do vinho era
mesmo como é que é possível
não sou muito eu jogo muito bom para o
pessoal agora vou tentar chutar esta
bomba contra a parede o ensinou muito
alto e para lá está em produção
aí não deu ser preso o indivíduo só não
faz isso em casa
efe
até mesmo algo assim esta balança existe
tudo está completamento dona intacta
falta muito com muita força agora 31 vai
ver que é possível impressionante série
para lá pessoal agora um texto mais
exigente da nossa bola vou tentar tirar
o máximo do alto possível e vamos ver o
que acontece para 3 2 1
ai meu deus está muito alta
como é possível não condicionada é muito
elástica essa boa eu vou tentar outra
vez agora para lá três noites
ae
não aconteceu rigorosamente nada intacta
agora vou tentar chutar a bola no chão
com muita força só para ver se o meu pé
entra aqui dentro para 321 vai à ópera
muito dura é muito dura tal não
aconteceu nada só entrou um pouco dentro
mas esta parte foi quem bateu na parede
não foi nem entrou no meu pé é
impossível é muito dura
outra vez para 31 vai lançar em muito
dura série não prevê para dentro recebe
não dá
bora lá pessoal agora vai ser o do
gênero o teste com a nossa bola
saltitante e eu vou tirá-lo de kehl
janela ali
agora é só seguir até o terceiro andar
que vamos ver o que acontece branco
resistiu
foi isso ela aí só ficou aqui mais
quadrada mas está aqui novinha em folha
mas aquela assistiu esta queda vamos
fazer um teste com água
bora lá aqui só temos aqui no meio do
jardim e agora vamos ver se essa bola o
futuro aluno pantano eu estou muito
curioso porque estava dizendo que
supostamente futuro é uma esponja sei lá
mas vamos ver estou muito cansado este
teste é que causam 321 futura mesmo tua
mesmo
obama tem um tempo que dois quilos três
filmes bfi do futuro é e fica muito bom
pessoal está aqui tem que ter um homem e
agora eu muito lucro a lei está em curso
acho que está aqui e tipo de solo na
água acham que sou estes ovos na água
então está sujeita terras que não é
verdade os irmãos mas agora que eu vou
fazer eu vou tentar tirar muito aproxima
e vamos ver o que acontece aqui na água
para lá e continuar essa bola é para
todos - disse ela com água continuar a
saltar eu vou estar aqui vejo isso vai
ainda falta ainda salta está muito mais
mole consiga formar os dentes muito
melhor
olha aí está mais maleável quando isso
aqui está parecendo a cabeça do monstro
cheira muito mal também é ok só vamos
tentar jogar futebol é assim
mais uma rodada
o loucos mas bom pessoal eu acho que já
não dá pra fazer muito mais coisas rico
islâmico exato de terras em d'água e
acabem gente e é isso que justifica
porque com estúdios vocês que estarão
distribuídos em muito a equipe foi novos
aqui no canal i am
se quiserem ver mais qualquer tipo de
vídeo com esta pasta com este plano como
tem uma idéia e 2 pessoal fiquem bem até
a próxima